all right that means it's time for
drew's news the only news that feels
like
finding an extra surprise french fry at
the bottom of the bag my favorite that's
right that's always fun and with me at
the desk he loves fries and waffle
shapes
rossi ross matthew annotator
a tater tot oh my god the most
underrated potato product is it tater
tot can i get an amen thank you so much
what is this
it's a boot and i just want to give a
special shout out to the dallas cowboy
cheerleaders because they sent this epic
pair of cowboy boots and they all signed
it
omg i know
that is so cool
i just
i really wanted to say thank you and how
much that meant to me and i thank you
from the bottom of my heart and i'm just
going to keep it here to you know spread
the cheer i'll boot that right and hey i
just wanted to say shout out to the uh
the cowboys they're seven and four
they're leading the nfc east uh playoff
bound keep it up
all right well december
um welcome to the mariah carey season
for holiday anthem all i want for
christmas turns 27 this year and it
hasn't aged a day it earned her 60
million dollars in royalties wow not bad
for a song this is true she wrote in 15
minutes yeah
only miranda in style reports that
mariah's got a brand new holiday special
on apple tv i actually watched last
year's it was really fun um and she made
her holiday rounds and revealed a big
relationship deal breaker on the show if
you're not into the holidays she's not
into you yeah that makes sense yeah if
you want to ride in her sleigh you
better jingle all the way
it makes sense
rossi
did you like not date someone who wasn't
super holiday gung-ho yeah i mean i'm
i'm pretty holly jolly i'm hojo to the
max i put up my tree like as i'm chewing
the last bite of turkey on thanksgiving
anybody else do that wait
and so
why that's important i think it's
because it means you're spirited
and you value that time which is all
about family and tradition and that's
important to me you
i have learned that it's about choosing
your battles
and that for me isn't one of them really
i just don't care you don't love the
holidays that doesn't bother me i've got
enough spirit to go around for everybody
i guess it's true
do any of you love and miss that old
norman lear classic the facts of life
yeah
yes
great news everybody it is coming back
to tv but for one night only tv line
reports abc's airing a live in front of
a studio audience special recreating an
old episode of facts of life remember
they've done this sort of thing before
and they've got an a-list cast listen to
this catherine hahn is joe allison
tolman is natalie gabrielle union is
tutti and jennifer aniston is blair
jennifer hanson jennifer aniston x blair
right
do you think she'll feather her hair
like blair used to have it feathered
remember the full pharah and what about
this everyone's know who is playing mrs
garrett
well none other than ann dowd from the
handmaid's tale which is
such great casting
emmy winner
i feel like everybody watching it is
going to be scared of her at first at
first but she's like such a warm sweet
actress which she is not that look at
her in the handmaid's tale aunt lydia
freaks me out and it's a double feature
for her because right after facts of
life they're going to do an episode of
different strokes which mrs garrett was
also in remember
so she's going to play myself in that
kevin hart is going to be playing arnold
and david wayne's what you're talking
about he's going to be playing willis
and john lithgow is mr drummond i know
how fun is that i love that
okay so it airs tuesday on abc at 8pm
eastern
and um i really loved joe of course she
was so hot right yeah she was like i i i
wasn't a blair type even though i was
obsessed with lisa welch of course i
loved tutti i loved natalie's
personality but the one i kind of wanted
to be like the most was joe i am a mrs
garrett through and through
oh my god i'm on time i have a sensible
bedtime
they say that there's going to be a
couple surprises as well so do you think
george george clooney remember he was on
oh please george clooney yeah hello
anderson you know he's calling george
clooney right now and being like come
come have fun zoom in from italy baby
we'll take what we can get yeah right
okay well we're there for this um next
time it's time for a pic from the little
yellow book and that is my personal
guide for all things that i would love
to share with you
and the truth is we all work on it here
on the show we all come up with stuff
because life is about sharing and
curating um and it's on our website we
refresh it every week
refresh
today we're keeping the holiday spirit
going move over mariah
matthews is a coming to town rossi
yeah well this is very fun you know um
you know i'm a judge on rupaul's drag
race and rue has extended the whole
just got all of us together for a brand
new holiday movie it's called
it's called the [ __ ] who stole
christmas
and it premieres tonight on vh1 at 9pm
eastern
i'm in it
i play a character very far from myself
named moss matthews
wait no that's not right matt roth use
whatever it doesn't matter take a look
at me in my christmas movie oh
it is a beautiful winter evening here in
tuckahoe and the perfect night to kick
off the annual winter ball isn't that
right creston carsley oh it sure is matt
rothfus
[Applause]
so we are like um
we're the announcers through the whole
movie it's super cute and really
hilarious well i'm so excited we all
need christmas
spirit and joy except for someone i may
date in the future who doesn't like it
[Music]